okay so before we before we get started
here I thought it would be a good idea
maybe to begin the show with a little
bit of motivation because you know
things can get kind of heavy here on the
show sometimes we get into some
difficult topics and so I thought we
could begin with a little pep talk some
inspiration so I'm gonna play this for
you briefly and I and I and I hope that
you find it as inspiring as I did she
just shoots up that big spirit or
presence or soul or whatever word you
like to use for it for ground zero
planet Earth just weeks is up and out
I'm moving her up so it doesn't get
stuck and all the astral currents it
doesn't get tangled yeah so so there's
so there's that there's there's there's
that anyway I bet that's all I can't
that's moving on I wrote an article
yesterday making a point that I've made
before on the show but I think it bears
repeating
I was thinking initially about the the
cultish support that Beto O'Rourke is
inspiring and you can't really call it
support actually because support is
conditional when you support a
politician that usually means that you
like what they stand for and the
policies that they propose but if they
betray those those principles then
you'll you'll stop supporting it so
that's what usually support means so
what Beto has our our groupies who
creates you know the there if you go
online you'll YouTube you'll find the
people have written songs about Beto
Roarke so that's that's these are
groupies and this is how you know as
I've said before this is how you know
that Beto will be the Democratic nominee
just because he gets that out of people
he doesn't have any policy proposals to
speak of no discernible vision for
America no qualifications really but he
makes people swoon for whatever reason
and they climb over each other to get
autographs and things like that and
that's all you need these days in
America it's why it's why you know Dre
or Bradley Cooper or or Tom Brady that
any of them could be President if they
wanted to be the only thing saving us
from a a car DB presidency is that she's
not old enough and she could probably
make more money in rap music but we
really are at a point I believe where
any pop star any famous athlete could be
president and you might say well it's
always been that way I don't think it
necessarily has always been that way I
think it's I think it's that way now
where if you have someone who just it
really the qualifications really don't
matter at all anymore
now I think is where we are it's great
for politicians if they can provoke that
sort of reaction but it's terrible for
America and it's deadly to democracy no
American and I I will keep beating this
drum because someone needs to I think no
American should ever be a fan of a
politician politicians should never have
fans conditional skeptical critical
support is the most that these people
should ever get from us ever fandom is
is something that's meant for sports
it's meant for Hollywood but it's not
meant for DC it's not meant for politics
and this is not I'm not just talking
about Democrats here Trump also Donald
Trump has many fans of his own obviously
as you know and and when I say fans of
Trump I'm talking about the sicko fans
who when it comes to the president they
lose all capacity for critical thought
sorry I'm not talking about the
president I'm saying no they don't call
it you know the people that they don't
say oh the president Donald Trump no
they say um they say my president have
you noticed that this is something that
you see you see it from from Trump fans
even more than you saw it from Obama
fans but Trump's most loyal fans when
they refer to him they'll say something
like they'll say something like you know
the establishment is always attacking my
president my
president deserves support my god it's
disgusting you you talk about him like
he's literally your boyfriend or
something yeah he is in a sense your
president in the in the in the in a
sense that you're an American citizen
but my president the thing is you would
never when Obama was president you never
said that you never said my President
Obama even though you reserve it for
Trump because you because this is a
weird affection you have from it's
really just gross nauseating but this
kind of support it by the way it's just
as bad on the other side when you've got
people say he's not not my president
right well he is he's all of our prezi
he's not your president he's not not
your president he's just the president
he's the president United States doesn't
belong to you you can't disown him
either he's just the guy who's the
president that's all this is the kind of
support though the kind of fandom that
Trump provokes in some people whatever
they do he supports whatever he says
they agree with whoever he villian
eise's they hate whoever he promotes
they love it really is as simple as that
they would quite literally drink the
kool-aid Jim Jones style if he asked
them to I really believe that they are
not conservative they're not right-wing
it would be it would be inaccurate to
classify them that way they are trumpets
who subscribe to trumpism and the
doctrines of trumpism can change from
moment the moment depending on what the
president or what my president happens
to be tweeting at the moment I remember
last week just as an example whenever I
think it was last week maybe the week
before when Trump randomly started
criticizing the the airline industry
right Trump Trump came out and said that
planes are too complicated and we need
to go back to old and simple planes
because right that's what you want when
you sit down you know for a flight and
the captain comes on the speaker what
you want to hear him say is all right
folks thanks for joining us I hope
you'll enjoy this flight on this old and
simple plane but Trump says we need old
and
simple planes and so all of his fans
though decided in that moment they said
you know what yeah we do actually yeah I
think we do need only there's there's a
huge praten now that you mention it
there is a huge problem of planes being
too complex
we need older simpler planes these are
people they never thought that before
none of them ever said that before this
is never an issue they ever thought
about but now they have adopted that
position wholeheartedly and they will
defend it passionately just because
Trump said it if Trump had said the
opposite of trouble if Trump came out
the next day and said you know what we
need more complicated planes these same
people would say yes this is what I've
been saying all along
we need more complicated planes many of
these same people spent eight years
criticizing this mentality among Obama's
most dedicated admirers and for good
reason Obama was worshipped with
religious fervor I'm sure you remember
that the religious devotion that Obama
had was was horrifying to witness and it
did a Norma's damage to our country and
it prevented Obama from ever being held
accountable for anything he did but the
celebrity a'f ocation of DC if we can
call it that if I can coin a word it
didn't end when Obama rode his White
Steve steed out of town into the sunrise
or the sunset I suppose it didn't end
there because those who had been busy
decrying the celebrity presidency a lot
of those very same people became
basically giggling schoolgirls as soon
as Trump arrived on the scene and so it
it is all very sickening it is a
disorder in the human mind that causes
us to venerate politicians in this way
we should identify this disorder within
ourselves and do our best to set it into
proper order if we if we recognize
within ourselves this instinct this
desire this inclination to worship
politician to see them as more than just
a politician to have excessive
admiration for if we see that within
ourselves we should try to get rid of it
we should try to kill it because it's
not healthy our first reaction to every
politician always no matter their party
should be suspicion we should be
suspicious of all of them I think a good
American is always suspicious of any man
or any woman who seeks to gain power
over him because when someone is running
for president or they're running for any
political office what they're saying is
I want to have control over you I want
power over you now they might not say it
in terms quite that direct although I
would almost respect them more if they
did but that is really what they're
saying implicitly what they're saying is
I want control and power over you now
anyone anyone who says that anyone we
should stop and say hey whoa okay but
hold on and immediately we should be
given them the side-eye
it's possible that a person might seek
this power for benevolent reasons it's
possible but it's extremely unlikely
there have perhaps been a few benevolent
rulers in American history maybe there
have been a few there are none today in
Washington not a single one the best we
can usually hope for and the best we
have available on the current scene are
vain self-serving politicians whose
vanity and self-interest are regulated
by certain useful qualities and some
correct ideas about laws and policies
that's the best we can usually hope for
and that's that's the that's the best
we're gonna get right now is that now
most politicians have the first base
covered so they've got the vanity and
they've got the self-interest the
problem is they don't have any of the
rest of the stuff they don't have any
positive qualities to speak of and they
don't have any correct ideas really to
compensate for all of the vanity and the
self-interest so that's most politicians
a few of them have a somewhat acceptable
but tenuous balance of the two well yeah
they're definitely vain as hell they
definitely are self-interested
they certainly are primarily concerned
about their own power but they do also
have some some positive qualities and
they do have correct ideas whether they
say so there are a few politicians that
we can say who we could say that for I I
might be maybe I'm being slightly unfair
there might be like two or three who are
even a little better than that and maybe
you know maybe there are a few who are
poor slightly better than that but this
is generally the case so these people
can earn our support I'm not saying that
we can never support a politician that
would be ridiculous they can earn our
support but if we're wise and if we have
the good of the country always in mind
then our support will only ever be shaky
and cautious and we will remain ever
ready to scold them like untrained
puppies if they go wrong and if they if
and we should be prepared to abandon our
support for them completely to drop them
to kick them to the curb we should be
prepared to do that if they reveal
themselves to be vacuous idiots or
morally corrupt scumbags without even a
hint of the positive qualities that we
imagined we originally detected so
that's the that's the I think the
approach we should have there's a great
JRR tolkien quote and this was a guy who
obviously knew something about the way
that power corrupts because he wrote a
whole book series about it but this is
what Tolkien said he said the most
improper job of any man even Saints who
at any rate were at least unwilling to
take it on is bossing other men
not one in a million is fit for it and
Li and least of all those who seek the
opportunity so there's an important
truth here almost nobody is really fit
to lord over other people to rule them
to have the sort of control over them
that our politicians in modern America
have over us almost nobody has fit for
that very very very very few people have
the moral character and the integrity
and even the wit or the intelligence
competence skill to be fit for that kind
of job and that kind of responsibility
and that kind of power and the problem
is that if they go seeking the job
that's a pretty good sign that they
aren't fit for it so that's the paradox
here that that you know the number one
way you could tell that someone isn't
fit to have that kind of power is if
they want it and almost everyone in
Washington today they're there because
they wanted it but someone has to do it
right and we do need a government
unfortunately otherwise we would have
anarchy but this isn't just all the more
reason to have skepticism and caution
when it comes to these people yeah if a
political candidate is asked in a
softball question if they're asked like
you know why are you running but what
attracted you to public service or
whatever the kind of question that a
Democrat would be asked asked on CNN or
a Republican would be asked on Fox and
when they're asked that question they'll
always say something like well I've
always wanted to help others I just have
a passion for helping or they'll say
something like like well there are a lot
of problems in America and I want to you
know get in there and help fix those
problems I'm running because I love my
country and I want to do what's best for
my country and blah blah blah you can
tell the real fans the real sycophants
if they actually believe that nonsense
when their favorite politician says it
the ones who actually believe that the
ones who say oh yeah Beto is running
because he just he really wants to solve
our problems or when Trump fans I I hear
from Trump fans who will say that that
well you know Trump ran because of his
deep abiding love for America and his
self-sacrifice and he just loves America
and American people so much and that's
why he ran oh please I I mean could good
lord I you can't be that naive
it's embarrassing no that is not why
either of those guys ran for office and
we need to understand that or we will
lose our republic we will lose our
freedom unless we have some healthy
skepticism about these people we need to
understand human nature that is not why
the vast majority of people seek power
it is not because they love you and they
really want to help you it's not what
it's about in in you know in almost
every case so am I being cynical yes
absolutely I am cynical but if you are
not cynical at this point about our
leaders then you have not been paying
attention all right so let's take a look
at something a little different here I'm
gonna play a video for you with warnings
ahead of time that you might find it a
little bit upsetting it's not graphic or
bloody or anything like that but it does
show an animal getting killed so this is
a video that's been going viral on
social media
not sure how and how it ended up on the
internet going viral but it's well
presumably the hunter put it on the the
Internet but it's a it's a video of a
big-game hunt in Africa and this hunter
I'm not gonna give his name his name has
been put out there now but I'm not gonna
do that
but he flew over from Illinois to do
this
they want to be behind that cheddar on
this Monday coming down
watch it if that was killer okay okay
don't anymore that mr. Kuney is a very
nice life
I'd answer very nice line beautiful that
is an exceptional line okay so he's
sleepy kills a sleeping lion and he
seems to be rather impressed with
himself after killing the sleeping
animal this video as you might expect
has provoked a strong reaction from
people and listen I'm not much of an
animal rights activist I'm really not
PETA is not going to be accepting me
into their ranks anytime soon I have no
problem with hunting
I don't really hunt myself it's just not
I I don't really I don't have anything
against it I just don't do it
I do fish I like the fish as I mentioned
before where I live there's a lot of
hunting a lot of fishing and so it's not
like I'm some sheltered urban dweller
scandalized by the whole concept of
outdoor activities I have also made the
point in the past just to say this up
front that people seem to get more
outraged about a video like that of a
lion being killed than they do about the
60 million babies who have been
slaughtered by abortion since Roe and
that is a deep sickness in our culture a
sign of a deep sickness now we care more
about the lion than we do about the
babies so those are two sort of
preliminary disclaimers with that said
however the idea of flying all the way
to Africa to kill a lion while it sleeps
is just completely bizarre and weird and
and it does seem awfully cowardly the
worst part is that if you kill a
sleeping animal then for you this the
thrill of it must simply be killing
right there's no sport there's no
pursuit there's no challenge anyone can
kill a sleeping animal any any idiot can
do that it's not difficult to do it
would be like as I said I like fishing
so it would be like if I were walking
down to the lake to go fishing and
I happen to see a big ol 8 pound bass
flapping around on the bank that somehow
got itself stranded and it would be as
if I walked up to that bass and I just
stabbed it in the head now if I was
starving or if I was even if I was out
in the woods or something I didn't have
anything to eat and I needed to eat and
I saw the bass there I would certainly
kill it and and I would eat it
and I would be thankful for that for for
it being so easy but if I'm just going
out to fish for fun I'm not going to
randomly kill the thing all right what
I'll do is I'll throw it back and then
I'll go and try to catch it again
because that's the whole fun of it and
if I catch it I'll throw it back again
because I don't I'm not actually gonna
kill it for me the point of fishing is
not to kill fish it's just it's for me
the with fishing it's fun to be outside
in the water in nature trying to find
where the fish are so there's kind of
the game the gamesmanship there the the
challenge of actually catching them
there's the thrill of getting the pull
on the line and everything and so I just
find all that really fun and yeah the
bragging rights of catching a really big
fish but but what I'll do is I catch a
really big fish I'll take a picture of
it and and then I'll have the picture
and that's the bragging rights I almost
always throw it back because for me it's
the enjoyment is is just in catching it
and all the things I just said it's not
in killing something even if it is just
a fish but as I said I have no problem
with hunting as long as the meat is used
for something killing a deer and eating
it is perfectly ethical I think and
helpful there's definitely a problem of
overpopulation of deer especially in
some parts of the country like where I
live you know you get deer all over the
place and they're a danger to people run
into them people are killed and driving
down the street so but even with a deer
you know I would think that if you were
going hunting for a deer and you saw one
sleeping you're not gonna kill a
sleeping deer are you unless unless
again unless you really need the meat
and you got to feed your family in which
case yeah you'll take whatever you can
get however you can get it that makes
total sense but if it's about the sport
of it it would be completely lame and
unethical and wrong to just kill a
sleeping deer
so tell me that you love hunting because
you're out in the woods and you're
pursuing it and you're tracking and
you're dealing with with all the
challenges and so on I understand that
that makes sense but if you like hunting
because you really just want to kill
something well then there's that's
disturbing
I think in that case you have
psychological problems yes
killing is part of hunting inevitably
but it shouldn't be the point it
shouldn't be an end in itself is the
point and besides I think there is a
difference between a lion and a deer
right just like we see a difference
between a deer and a dog there's a
difference between these animals so if
you go out killing dogs for sport people
will think that you're a sick maniac and
and in that case you would be a sick
maniac we have a kind of hierarchy of
animals that we've established I don't
fully understand the hierarchy nobody
really does but it's there certain
animals we form a closer bond with like
dogs other animals we see as being more
beautiful more majestic like lions and
elephants are these subjective judgments
yeah I suppose they are but that doesn't
make them completely arbitrary or
meaningless either and the thing is the
lion hunter obviously shares that
feeling he obviously also thinks that
the lion is especially majestic and
beautiful that's why he goes all that
way and pays all that money to kill it
it's just that most of us when we see an
animal and we think wow that's a
majestic beautiful animal we just want
to look at it and maybe take a picture
and tell our friends about it whereas
this you know these people what they say
is oh that's a majestic beautiful animal
I would love to shoot it in the head and
that just find it bizarre
look I can't completely explain why a
dolphin is necessarily more valuable or
more precious or whatever than a bass it
has something to do with the Dolphins
intelligence it's assumed capacity for
pain and so on but there is more to it
than that isn't there and I can't
explain it exactly yet I'm not going to
go out and kill a dolphin because even
if I can't explain why we have this
ingrained priority system that doesn't
make it okay necessarily to just toss it
out the window and go kill whatever we
want you know it's I don't think that
justifies it now I know people will say
oh but lions are a problem in Africa and
they kill people they're dangerous and
besides these rich white dudes they go
and they they pay big money and and they
help the economy and they give the meat
to the villagers and all that all right
that's fine that's that's noted but
first of all Africans are perfectly
capable of killing dangerous animals
themselves they've been doing it for
thousands of years the idea that they
need to have a rich white dude come and
kill the lion for them is paternalistic
in the extreme and it's frankly just
ridiculous you think a couple of
Africans can't figure out how to kill a
sleeping lion you think they neat way
they need to call you know whoever this
guy was in Illinois hey get over here we
got a sleeping line and get over here
quick we need someone to kill we don't
know how to do it we need you no I don't
think so okay but the the white dude is
paying fine I get it you know he's
paying is paying a lot of money
financially it's helpful but that
doesn't really explain why the white
dude wants to go all that way and kill a
lion and it doesn't necessarily make it
ethical either so think of it this way
what if your friend had to put down his
dog right the dog is is is sick in pain
suffering gotta be put down that makes
sense totally ethical but then imagine
that you offer to pay your friend ten
thousand dollars so that you can be the
one to shoot it in the head well then
all of a sudden
this ethical mercy killing goes from
ethical mercy killing to snuff fetish
even if the dog needs to be killed even
if the ten grand will help your friend
that's all great but the fact that
you're so desperate to kill something
and that you would find pleasure in
killing this dog that says something
really disturbing about you and then it
is unethical and yeah now it wouldn't be
unethical to take the pet to the vet to
do but for you to do it all the sudden
is unethical because of your motivation
for you it's just it's your killing for
the sake of killing and that is that is
always the killing for the sake of
killing is always unethical always no
matter what your killing I mean if you
saw an ants crawling across the ground
and you just stepped on it for the sake
of it that would be unethical whereas if
you've got about you've of if you have
an ant infestation in your house and you
bring an exterminator and you kill
thousands of ants that's not unethical
at all the point is just killing the
kill is no matter what it is is wrong I
mean we walking by and you know pulling
up a flower just just because just to
kill it that would also be wrong is it
varying degrees of immoral certainly and
not all the same but the point is
killing for killing is wrong and in this
case killing it's killing for killing
and also killing because what you're
killing his majestic and beautiful and
exotic and I think that that just makes
it even more wrong because all right you
know whereas if it were the African
villagers doing it no problem you know
because they're the ones threatened by
the lion for them and it's not just
about killing the thing it's it's a
totally different situation so I don't
know I I it does seem to me to be
problematic I guess there's a there's a
larger conversation that could be had
about big-game killing and I'm not
saying that it's wrong in every context
but definitely killing a sleeping animal
is just
all right uh let's see here maybe we'll
say up okay here's one more thing to
play for you also disturbing this is
from something called now this news and
it's a news or a news organization that
clearly as you'll be able to tell
approves of what you're about to witness
so watch this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so we've got a drag brunch a brunch
where people brought their kids so that
cross-dressing men with stage names like
Cummings could dance for them did you
notice that that boy's father you know
boy appeared to be sitting on his dad's
lap and his dad was filming the whole
thing and that's the most tragic thing
about that video clip is that boys need
and deserve real fathers and instead it
appears that this young boy
unfortunately has not real father but a
an effeminate emasculated coward as his
father I mean I there are a lot of other
ways I could describe this guy the kind
of man that would bring his son to
something like that and then be
delighted when this cross-dressing
person is dancing in front of them I
just I can't wrap my head around it but
what you find there again is this this
in insistence in combining drag queens
and kids it's like everywhere you said
we talked about it earlier this week
they they have data crossdresser come
into a kindergarten classroom and read a
book about about transgenders and then
they've got the drag queen story hours
and they've got I mean now this is a
constantly the left is trying to combine
kids and drag queens as much as possible
why do you think that is well we know
what it is it's about brainwashing them
while they're young and it's a but this
is you know what you saw in that video
there this is these are key digit kids
who are being groomed this is the
grooming of children happening right in
front of our eyes all right let's go to
some emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com
Matt Walsh show at gmail.com this is
from Lisa as hey Matt I appreciate how
you approach topic so I thought I would
ask your take
a topic ally Beth Stuckey the
conservative millennial mentioned on her
podcast on Monday ally believes the left
is tried to change the narrative of the
pro-life movement the left is trying to
convince pro-lifers that abortion is
just merely one facet of pro-life that
if you were really pro-life you would
fight for the babies and cages of the
borders the immigrants transgender the
women who need the abortion etc what
about their lives don't they matter - I
tend to agree with her opinion in that
the more I look around my social circles
I find this to be true my philosophy on
that though is if you compromise on the
killing of innocent children where else
can you go from there abortion has to
matter more because there will be
literally nothing left if it doesn't of
course I would love your take on this
idea of expanding the definition of
pro-life and possibly some ways to
combat this way of thinking
yeah Ally is is right about that now
it's it's true that the pro-life
movement and it's important to stipulate
I think the pro-life movement is not
necessarily a movement limited only to
abortion though abortion is the central
fight it's the most important fight but
there is a pro-life ethic that extends
beyond abortion the point is that life
is sacred and valuable that's our
message as pro-lifers that's what we're
saying
life is sacred and valuable which life
or any life all in all human life is is
sacred and valuable and it's never okay
to kill a human being it's never okay to
kill an innocent human being you know
never okay that's our principle that's
the banner that we wave right the
problem is that the left is trying to
it's not even that they're just trying
to expand what pro-life means it's that
they're trying to miss apply that ethic
to misappropriate it and claim that for
instance if you oppose illegal
immigration then you're doing something
that is in opposition to the pro-life
ethic but that of course is absurd it's
absurd for many reasons first of all
nobody is advocating killing immigrants
no one is saying we should murder them
so this is not a so this is not a
life-or-death thing
all we're saying is that if you want to
come to this country you should come
legally and in fact that if if we can
apply the pro-life ethic to the
immigration debate at all I think we
apply it on the side of immigration
enforcement because when you don't
enforce the borders and when you've got
porous borders then you've got as
president tribes pointed out many times
you've got you know drug dealers coming
across human traffickers illegal
immigration is deadly to human beings
many people have been killed not just by
illegal immigrants but in the process of
immigrating illegally so it is about
protecting law and order and it's also
about preserving human life and and some
of these other issues they mentioned
just again have nothing at all to do
with with you know with the issue at all
it's just a separate issue entirely yeah
they'll throw in something other than
you mentioned transgenders well I
thought you're pro-life what does that
have to do with so because I'm pro-life
that means I have to agree that a man
can be a woman if he puts on a dress it
just makes no sense whatsoever so yeah
that's the that's the only thing I would
add to that is that it's it's not even
it's not just expanding but it is
expanding it is in fact taking the the
pro-life position and sort of hijacking
it for their own purposes all right this
is from Wes and says hey Matt firstly
thanks for being a rare nun by his voice
of reason your show keeps me sane in
regards to current events quick question
the recent tragedy in Christchurch has
seen the usual conspiracy theorists hard
at work this has been the case with most
landmark events in recent history I find
it frustrating and genuinely a generally
disrespectful of the victims and their
families
well I wouldn't consider myself a
conspiracy theorist I can often see the
logic and how people might arrive at
alternative conclusions given the
evidence or lack thereof I'd love to
hear your thoughts on which recent
events in fact tread uncomfortably close
to conspiracy ie Titanic versus Olympic
jet fuel melting the
trade buildings of in Gaza cover-up etc
yeah there are there are obviously
people who look for conspiracies in in
every tragedy every shooting every mass
casualty event like you point out those
people are fools and as you say they're
disrespectful to the victims I will just
clarify that most of the time they have
no logic on their side I think you're
being a little bit too generous to them
there is no logic to their position at
all most of the time they latch on to
one or two talking points one or two
little holes that they think they find
in the official narrative which most of
the time that those holes can be
explained if they were just willing to
listen to the explanation which they're
not and from there they build a
mythology which is based entirely in
their imagination that said conspiracies
do sometimes happen ben ghazi sure i
mean that was a conspiracy in a certain
sense there were you know bad decisions
mistakes were made by the government
that led to those people being killed at
the consulate the conspiracy though was
afterwards when they got when certain
members high-ranking members of the
government got together and decided that
their official narrative was going to be
we're gonna blame this on a YouTube
video so yeah that was a conspiracy it
wasn't like a conspiracy that was
cinematic in its scope or anything like
that but it was a conspiracy in the
sense that they did conspire to blame
this on something that it couldn't have
been blamed on and yeah I mean we can
imagine that they literally sat down and
they met and they conspired and they
said what are we gonna pin this on let's
do the YouTube video that was a
conspiracy
the thing is conspiracies in real life
oftentimes are not very complex don't
involve a lot of people that's one of
the problems with the extravagant
conspiracy theory theories that the
conspiracy theorists come up with is
that invariably they involve
thousands of people across decades
sometimes like with the moon-landing
thing and it just involved and they're
so complicated it would require so many
people to be on the same page and to
keep the secret and to not talk about it
and to be very competent in the way that
they execute it and it's just that's not
the way it works especially in
government where you've got some of the
most incompetent people on the planet in
government and they're simply not
capable of something like that
so the Benghazi conspiracy was was we
know that it was real and it looked real
because it was very incompetent very
clumsy it involved you know relatively
small number of people and at the end of
the day it was easy to detect so I think
that's how you can tell the real
so-called conspiracies all right I think
we'll leave it there and we'll reconvene
tomorrow have a great day Godspeed